you know one of the biggest things about
this is people have been saying we need
to have conversations we need to have
the uncomfortable conversations
um people white people people that are
non-black need to talk about
and accept where their blind spots are
what they need to change have you seen
this happening are you experiencing this
happening with people that you know
the first thing and it's a good thing
that and people may criticize me for
this statement
but it's a good thing that this hate has
been unleashed
because now we know what we have to fix
i've never seen this i didn't know
people
i really didn't i didn't know that there
was
this much evil i mean the
extreme hate that
some of the trump voters are displaying
is is well it's arresting i have to say
i've never seen anything like it and yet
it's been going on since this country
was
developed
and i'm sorry but there's a price for
killing
all of those native americans there's a
price
for bringing us here against our will
in the bowels of ships you know there
can be no healing until somebody says
i'm sorry
nothing can heal and unfortunately we
have a leader
who i have to say is completely out of
his mind
i know what mental illness looks like
and he is mentally ill
and we're we're suffering because of it
i don't hate donald trump i feel sorry
for him
larry king asked me when he first was
elected what would i say to him
and he thought i was going to say
something maybe mean and nasty
but i would have said one thing to him
step down sir you're unfit
and you're incapable of leading
a great nation my people
my people took the hoses and the dogs
on the front line in the 60s and that
should have been enough
but obviously it was not
and now those kids the millennials they
have to rise up
and fight the same war
i want to apologize to them because we
should have done more
my generation should have done more
it's horrible what's happening right now
all around the world not just here
but we we had pride ourselves on being
leaders you can't
lead with all of this hate
we have got to come together we cannot
let this
self-centered
there are too many words to call and we
can't let this one man
start a civil war in the united states
america
it cannot happen and if i have anything
to do with it
it won't happen on my watch sir
blackish has addressed police brutality
a lot of things that people are waking
up to
um now and that the episode was
years ago even um
are you going to be bringing what's
happening in the world
now uh into storylines moving forward
oh absolutely absolutely you know i've
always said the
the writers are the stars of blackish oh
it would be impossible not to address
covet 19
and all that's going on in the world and
i'm looking forward to it we have great
writers
and the cast is very excited to get back
we don't know
how we're going back yet uh with all the
new rules
and that's why i tell people
it's time to love harder than we've ever
loved before
some of the things we used to do we
ain't gonna be able to do
no more you know
blackish i'm excited to go back to the
seventh season